bah un jour ils ont dit c'est sûr c'est
une prison ton foyer et je leur ai dit
que c'est pas ça du tout un foyer merci
bisous
oui à des personnes qui s'occupent de
nous parce que nos parents ils peuvent
pas s'occuper de nous on est là pour eux
on fait comme on peut quoi
mais pourquoi tu me dis que tu as peur
de mourir
[Musique]
qui ont bien mis en fait
si on avait une grande famille
salut c'est Juliette et aujourd'hui je
voulais vous parler des maisons
d'enfants à caractère social
c'est-à-dire des mecs en gros ce sont
les établissements dédiés à l'accueil
temporaire d'enfants en difficulté pour
vous raconter le quotidien d'une de ces
maisons je suis partie à Annecy à la
rencontre de Lauréline elle a 26 ans et
elle est éducatrice dans la protection
de l'enfant depuis 5 ans
vous avez tous à manger là
surtout pas le matin
parce que après ça vous empêche de vous
concentrer à l'école
[Musique]
coucou loulou pour que vous compreniez
un peu plus la vie en foyer je tenais
aussi à vous montrer le quotidien d'une
des jeunes placés elle s'appelle evanina
elle a 8 ans et c'est Lauréline son
éducatrice référente
[Musique]
bah là il y a moi avec mes deux poupées
là c'est un dessin que j'ai fait
de danseuse
je suis en maillot de corps et là
bah je suis bah
ça c'était une jupe pour le genre de
spectacle là il y a mes choses tendance
là il y a mon collant mon papier ma
mamie là il y a moi là
trois ont été arrivés quand tu avais
quel âge 6 ans
tu as pas fait tes dents
[Musique]
bonne journée bisous
se retrouvent à la maison des enfants
justement les enfants se retrouvent
après ils sont placés par la juge des
enfants donc il y a une mesure
judiciaire qui est mis en place et du
coup ils sont placés souvent suite à des
violences conjugales
enfin sois violent conjugale violence
physique
[Applaudissements]
maltraitance psychologique ou physique
même violence
sexuelle abus
au déficience des parents des fautes
soin aussi
les transmissions
ça c'est la partie que j'adore c'est la
vue qu'on a de la maison des enfants
et pour être honnête tout le monde n'a
pas cette chance
le cas de travail est quand même très
idyllique
et là-bas on voit le petit lac d'Annecy
ou plutôt l'immense lac d'Annecy
on y va
du coup tu as réussi ton test c'est
génial bravo fier de toi que du coup tu
as été au delà tes peurs donc ça c'est
trop bien
oui on a déjà posé beaucoup de questions
sur le foyer un jour ils ont dit c'est
sûr c'est une prison ton foyer
et moi j'ai pris ça bah méchamment
mais vraiment méchamment
[Musique]
mais en tout cas ça m'a fait de la
tristesse et je sais pas pourquoi
en tout cas le foyer c'est pas comme une
prison on fait des sorties on fait des
trucs chouettes
et ça c'est bien c'est pas comme dans
une prison
[Applaudissements]
les enfants est-ce que vous savez
pourquoi vous êtes ici tous à peu près
de moi c'est ça
et toi tu prends comment
tu comprends
très très très naturel
parce que là je suis elle est pas encore
c'est pas que la juge pourquoi vous
pouvez pas rentrer
nos parents ils savent pas trop pas du
tout parce que nos parents
bah là ils savent pas trop s'occuper de
nous en ce moment où ils peuvent même
pas du tout ils peuvent pas répondre à
vos besoins
allez on y va
on va se brosser les dents
souvent il y en a qui sont placés pour
justement des faux de soin donc par
exemple qui arrive avec plein de caries
ou des petits soucis au niveau bucco ça
a pas été acquis donc ça nous de revoir
les bases de repartir à zéro qui t'a
parfois reprendre jusqu'à voilà
reprendre comme les mains tout petit et
Yoni maintenant il adore ce coiffer le
matin il aime bien mettre du gel il aime
bien bien s'habiller par contre voilà il
des fois je pense pas changer ses
vêtements sales oui mélange le propre et
le sale Vanina c'est pareil des fois
tu es d'accord
bon maintenant il faut bien que tu étais
dictionnaire des mots
[Applaudissements]
ça sert à rien de pleurer pour ça
d'accord
je sais que tu sais le lac moi je suis
la ce weekend on pourra faire quelque
chose ce weekend
ok tu as mangé du Nutella
combien de tartines
tu t'es régalé non je t'ai régalé non tu
as pas aimé
[Musique]
Ina
tu viens
ok bah je lui dirai demain tu vas aller
au Lac avec maman
OK et là on reste sur deux heures et si
ça se passe bien cet été on augmentera
la visite trois heures peut-être
et après si ça se passe bien la rentrée
on pourra augmenter les droits
mais pour l'instant reste sur deux
heures pour voir comment ça se passe
mais si vous voulez goûter avec Eva Nina
chez vous c'est ok
[Musique]
ok super bah je vous passe les Vanina
je suis allée à la piscine toute la
journée aujourd'hui pareil et jeudi
encore ça sera pareil
[Applaudissements]
dormir oui
trop bien et je vais voir ma maman chez
elle tous les
mercredis
trop parce qu'avant tu la voyais où
c'est quoi
tous les enfants du foyer ou de la GG
Wailers parents avec un éducateur avec
un éducateur qui est le surveille
[Musique]
mais pourquoi tu me dis que tu as peur
de mourir il y a pas de raison
ici tu risques rien tu es en sécurité et
je sais pas d'où tu sors ça
tu fais de beaux rêves et tu penses à
des choses positives bisous
fais de beaux rêves à demain
et voilà
normalement c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
ça fait des années qu'on a cette musique
comme il a pu parler ça fait au moins
trois quatre ans qu'ils sont là et ils
peuvent pas ils ont du mal à s'en passer
sinon ça complique encore plus le
coucher
ça c'est mon moment préféré
le calme
les enfants sont couchés
donc ce soir il y en a qui étaient bien
content d'autres qui étaient un peu plus
triste de t'angoisser donc voilà dans
ces moments on est là aussi pour
rassurer les enfants et
pour être avec eux
et oui on est là pour eux on fait comme
on peut quoi
on donne de l'amour pas trop donne de la
fac pas trop
mais c'est important de demander
et si on a beaucoup de moyens
niveau financier c'est très correct mais
plus niveau professionnel on est en
manque de moyens quand même il faut
vraiment le vouloir je pense pour pour
tenir ici sur du long terme après c'est
plus personnel aussi je pense que tous
les éducateurs qui travaillent qui ont
choisi cette vocation c'est personnel
c'est un parcours de vie c'est une autre
histoire c'est
notre vécu c'est aussi on a tous je
pense que tout le monde ici a une part
vécue
difficile comme ses enfants en fait et
c'est je pense que c'est ça aussi pour
qu'on choisit l'éducateur pourquoi on
trait choisi de travailler avec des
imprimés
qui ont bien mou en fait pour commencer
et du coup c'est difficile de lâcher
c'est difficile de lâcher quand on est
chez nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va se réveiller c'est l'heure
c'est mercredi aujourd'hui
[Musique]
livraison
et vous la faites goûter oui ok faut
faire attention goûter qu'elle mange pas
enfin qu'elle se coiffe pas trop
ma maman et ça va être trop bien
parce que ouais bon parce que je sais
pas quoi mais en tout cas je sais que ça
va être trop bien
parce que là on va aller à casino et ça
va être trop bien parce qu'elle va
m'acheter un côté allez on est parti
on essaye de travailler au mieux avec
les parents de garder le lien avec les
familles pour pour qu'on travaille en
amont et voir qu'il y a une évolution
pour le jeûne pour qu'il soit heureux
pour enfin oui pour répondre à
ses besoins
[Musique]
et tu sais que tu vas chez papi mamie le
4 juillet
la semaine prochaine
non tu parles le cas donc faudra que tu
dises au revoir à tes copines lundi
bon tu nous fais un parcours là je le
montre tes talents
là en descendant ok
3 2
et moi j'ai une question escape employés
c'est comme avoir une grande famille bah
oui c'est exactement comme si on avait
une grande famille comme dans le dessin
animé bienvenue chez les Loudes
où il y a 10 enfants dans la famille et
deux adultes dans les deux adultes le
papa la maman
mais sauf que là il y a pas des
personnes de 17 ans ou de un an
Léonore elle est trop belle sa robe
on va aller au Lac
ok
parce qu'on est quel jour aujourd'hui on
est mercredi
alors je vais vous entendre chanter là
je la connais un peu
du canapé il est encais son petit frère
de ne pas trouver la femme de sa vie
mais mon pauvre Diego tu tiens tellement
trouver
ah il aurait dû y aller
j'ai pensé avoir de l'eau
on pense avoir de l'eau
[Musique]
1 2 3 soleil
encore un an ou deux ans je sais pas
mais à mon avis je vais pas rester
jusqu'à 18 ans
et j'espère pas à la rentrée evanina
elle rentrera dans un nouveau groupe
d'enfants plus âgés dans la maison des
enfants les jeunes échangent de groupe
et de éducateurs référents plus ou moins
tous les trois ans selon leur évolution
donc ça veut dire que si un jeune est
placé dès son plus jeune âge et reste
jusqu'à ses 18 ans il peut avoir environ
6 changements de groupe et d'éducateurs
référents au cours de sa vie au foyer
c'est horrible pour un enfant il va
s'attacher à un éducateur pendant deux
ans puis le jour d'après enfin on lui
dira c'est bon tu t'attaches à quelqu'un
d'autre puis enfin jusqu'à ses 18 ans et
c'est
en fait les gamins ce qu'ils ont vécu on
leur produit 5 6 fois des ils vivent le
rejet ils vivent là-bas nous constamment
en fait et pourquoi c'est comme ça
bah c'est de passer du temps avec ma
famille et de devenir danseuse
d'ailleurs de la danse j'en ai j'ai
partout des posters dedans ce jeune
guirlande j'ai même moi en
tenue alors
c'est ça
alors
et ton Maxence tu t'offres quoi pour la
Saint-Valentin bah rien je crois pas
envie et puis tu me caches le bronzage
va jouer ailleurs au contraire Wendy
c'est giga important de donner le goût
des tendances aux nouvelles générations
je fais le tour de la maison
je fais le tour de la maison je ferme
les volets c'était sur les escaliers et
je ferme la porte à clé
bonne nuit
à demain bisous bisous
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que vous a intéressé n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à notre chaîne pour
voir plus de contenu comme celui-ci et
si vous avez des idées de sujets que
vous voudrez que j'aborde vous pouvez
m'envoyer un message sur Instagram et je
vous dis à la prochaine
[Musique]